Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will
be my Spider-Man Across the spider-verse review
video this is meant to be part two of at least
a spider-verse Trilogy that we know of right now
they could always wind up making a fourth film
the first movie Spider-man into the spider-verse
is still one of the best Spider-Man movies of all
time so making a sequel that could hit that level
or be even better was a really tall order if
you're new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos I'm giving away tickets to
the movie to random commenters all you have to do
is enter is just be a subscriber and post your
favorite spider-verse moments from the trailers
so far on the video and please don't post spoilers
if you have seen the movie I'm working on videos
for the ending post-credits scene full breakdown
Easter eggs for everything that'll start posting
later this week after it comes out in theaters
just like I do for all my other movies Spider-Man
across the spider verse follows Miles Morales
about a year since becoming Spider-Man he's in his
second year of high school this time and has been
active as Spider-Man in the New York City area
having Adventures long enough that the local store
owners have started creating merch based on on
him the same way in the first movie that that big
Stanley Cameo scene was him selling the Spider-Man
Halloween costumes to miles but that was based on
that universe's version of Peter Parker Spider-Man
he enjoys being Spider-Man he's trying to deal
with being Spider-Man and trying to be a normal
kid at the same time like just go to school and be
Spider-Man at the same time he misses the rest of
the team from the first movie like Peter B Parker
and most of all spider Gwen who is going by the
name Spider Woman they refer to her several times
in the movie as Spider Woman I believe they also
made that change in the comics too where they just
call the character Spider Woman because if she
used Gwen in her name in her Universe everybody
would know instantly who she was more importantly
speaking of Gwen she's become a much bigger
character than she was in the first movie Haley
Steinfeld of course is amazing as the character I
really hope someday we'll get to see a live action
version of her she also plays Kate Bishop in all
the MCU stuff so that'd be a really funny scene
for them to try and pull off during Secret Wars
but when you think of the spider-verse movies you
mostly think of them as miles Alice movies with
many many in this case thousands of other versions
of Spider-Man running around but the sequel
actually elevates Gwen Stacy in the story to more
like a second main lead role in the opening of the
movie is completely dedicated to her it starts in
her Universe we learn more about her backstory her
character the relationship she has with the other
characters in her Universe the way that the people
of her New York think of her and her actions
throughout the movie Drive the plot just as Miles
Morales actions do I suspect that'll continue into
part three which will be just as big a character
as Miles Morales is the marketing for the movie
wanted you to think that the main villain is
actually Spider-Man 2099 played by Oscar Isaac
who returns from the post credit scene in the
first movie he's obviously fantastic in anything
he does it's fun to see him as Moon Knight in
the MCU stuff and now Spider-Man 2099 maybe if
we cross our fingers someday we'll also see him
as live action Spider-Man 2099 in his Universe
in the year 2099 like the comics he's created a
giant team of Multiverse versions of Spider-Man
called the spider force during the movie they're
dedicated to protecting what they call the Canon
which is what he calls the stability of the
Multiverse held together by a web-like structure
like the spider verse the spider web of timelines
in the comics and in the movie they also refer to
it as the spider-verse theory of the Multiverse
it's a different way of visualizing the Multiverse
but it's the same basic concept as what we saw
during the Loki series with all the timelines
all connected the movie is way more meta and way
more comic Booky than the first movie was if you
can believe that if you're not familiar with the
term Canon it's short for canonical it means it
represents the original author's continuity of
the story Universe like what they deem as the
actual story being for example in the MCU Marvel
movies Kevin feige is The Keeper of the Canon so
he says what is Canon and what is not so unless
Kevin foggy makes a change in a Marvel movie
it's not canon to the official overarching story
there'll be lots of questions about this this in
the next couple weeks because the whole Doctor
Strange Spider-Man no way home reference in all
the trailers where he calls the MCU Earth Earth
19999 and in the last few Marvel movies Kevin
feige has been calling it earth616. don't worry
I will address that during my full breakdown for
Easter eggs video it gets really technical in
the movie though it's something that they just
brush past by it doesn't stop the movie short or
anything like that like you don't get tripped up
on the logic which is another important detail
even though there are like a thousand different
Easter eggs in every single scene I'm gonna have
to watch the movie like five times just to do my
full breakdown video It Doesn't weigh the movie
Down especially if you're not a big comic book
fan or you haven't seen a ton of other comic
book movies or even Spider-Man movies but it
does work for the most hardcore Spider-Man stand
if you've seen Spider-Man everything if you're
walking around in Spider-Man PJs if you were
born watching Spider-Man stuff every movie every
TV show every comic book every product tie-in
even the toys going back to the classic toys are
referenced in this movie in some way they
throw down the gauntlet like even the most
Ardent Easter egg hunter will have to watch
this movie A Thousand Times the actual main
villain of the story for this part and for part
three beyond the spiderverse is the spot played
by Jason Schwartzman who has a special connection
with Miles Morales more so than any of the other
characters that goes back to Miles getting the
spider bite and becoming a version of Spider-Man
pretty much everyone from the first movie is back
some more so than others and there were so many
Cameo scenes that were not in the trailer ought
to talk about that later this week just because a
lot of them are really spoilery but they will blow
your mind with the whole Multiverse Kang Dynasty
Avengers 5 Avengers 6 Secret Wars of it all
everything is connected through the spider-verse
generally the themes of the movie are mostly about
this concept that it is possible to change the
Canon without completely destroying everything
that you love like you're a fan of something
someone can come along and do something that's
non-canonical and it won't completely destroy the
thing that you loved the idea that doing something
different and unexpected with pre-existing
characters and tropes can lead to amazing things
to make more Spider-Man puns the movie's full of
puns as you would expect the thing the movie does
really well like the deeper meaning of the movie
is in justifying Miles Morales existence as a
version of Spider-Man in the movie Universe like
in the story universe but also in real life like
we talk about movies justifying their existence
like why do we need 20 Avengers movies this movie
literally tells you why we need Miles Morales as a
character in real life if you don't know the story
behind the creation of Miles Morales Brian Michael
Bendis created the character after seeing Donald
Glover in real life wear a Spider-Man t-shirt
during an episode of community that's how new the
character Miles Morales is and the whole idea is
that at the time it was super controversial people
were like no way the Donald Glover could ever play
a version of Spider-Man so Brian Michael Bennis
is like you know what I'm gonna make him a version
of Spider-Man and that wound up being the Miles
Morales character essentially and now as we're
talking as me posting this video the movie across
the spider-verse basically takes that topic head
on like you'll understand once you see it the
whole message of the movie is that you can't
create some totally new version of Spider-Man who
isn't Peter Parker that doesn't look like this
and it won't destroy all of reality in all these
pre-existing Comics overall the story is great
I do have minor complaints about the way they cut
the ending though the whole part three beyond the
spider verse of it all just the way they edited
the ending that I'll address in a second all the
actors were amazing even the smaller Cameo actors
that just had really small speaking Parts there
were about 280 different versions of Spider-Man
in the movie but only about 95 of them are meant
to be versions from the comics that people who
are big comic book fans would recognize and of
those 95 only a handful of them actually have
speaking lines and you probably seen some crazy
theories that people have about the movie but
that doesn't cover the half of the stuff that
they pull off just talking about the animation
because the animation in the first movie was so
off the chain Sony even patented their animation
style from the first first movie nowadays spider
versus like a noun that people used to describe
that particular animation style like they started
using similar techniques in the new Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles movie and it looks great
it's like computer animation but done to look
like hand-drawn animation and where the movie
goes so hard like they didn't need to go this
hard but they totally did it is that for all
the different main versions of Spider-Man like
there are a handful that are main versions all
of them are animated in completely different
styles unique to the characters for example in
spider Gwen's Universe it looks kind of like this
like pastels the colors of the universe and the
characters while they're interacting also change
color based on her mood second to Second so this
is really cool effect of Shifting colors that you
see when you're in her Universe miles morales's
Universe even Spider-Man 2099's universe are
animated in a slightly more traditional style
Hobie brown spider Punk probably has the most
different looking animation he's played by Daniel
caluya who is in the first Black Panther movie
and I say of all the new big characters he's
probably one of my favorites just because I don't
consider Oscar Isaac's Spider-Man 2099 to be a new
character even though they changed the way that
his character model looks they made him look way
more monstrous for this movie but Hobie Brown's
spider Punk is animated in a very punk rock type
of style thematically he serves as a guide for
miles and Gwen and is this force of chaos and
rebellion in keeping with the tone and the origins
of his character like the name implies spider Punk
he feels like he's right out of that classic
Punk movement in real life they did a bunch
of new music and even though what's up danger in
the music from the first movie is so awesome it's
really hard to top Metro Boomin also made some
really cool new tracks they even gave him a cameo
in the movie he's in all the trailers he's the
guy with the joke about miles finding somewhere
else to run they brought on all new directors
working on this movie there was joaquinto Santos
who avatar The Last Airbender fans will remember a
lot of classic animation fans Ken Powers Justin K
Thompson they did a great job and the reason why
they need three directors for all these movies
like there were three directors on the first
spider-verse movie is because the movies are
so big it's so much work like it took them four
years just to get this out and part of the rumor
is that originally Spider-Man across the spider
verse was this giant movie that got so big that
they just split it in half in the second part like
part two wound up being beyond the spiderverse and
they'll release it next year and that's why it's
coming out next year not in another four years
like it would normally take like they pulled in
Avengers Infinity war in Avengers end game if you
remember when they first announced those movies
it was Infinity War part 1 and infinity War part
two just because they wanted to break the movie
into two halves but then they changed the name
to part two to Avengers end game just because
eventually the movie changed so much that it felt
like a completely different type of story overall
I think Spider-Man across the spiders came close
to topping the first movie it's at least tied now
for two of the top five Spider-Man movies of all
time and I really hope that part three beyond
the spider-verse is at least as good as this
was here's we get to a couple my minor complaints
though and it mostly has to do with the way they
edited the ending they definitely understood the
assignment that this was meant to be part one of
a part two movie like alright like they almost
felt like they ended right in the middle of a
sentence so to speak now it wasn't quite the
same as fast X they kind of did the same thing
with the recent Fast and Furious movie where they
literally just boom cut to Black like someone cut
it in the middle of a scene I saw an early version
of the movie so they might tweak this a little bit
in the final theatrical version but it did feel
like they just had an hard out like you know what
we're just gonna set all this stuff up and it was
almost a harder ending than Empire Strikes Back
I fully expect part 3 beyond the spiderverse to
pick up immediately where this movie leaves off
and maybe they'll introduce some feature when both
the Blu-rays for the movies eventually come out
in a couple years where you can just cue them
up like it just plays as a three hour movie it
just happens to be on two different discs so in
that way it's a little bit more like the Matrix
movies like Matrix Reloaded ends in a weird way
because you knew you were gonna get the rest of
the story in Matrix Revolutions within a couple
months we get to wait a year to get part three but
it won't be that long normally we'd be waiting
like four years for the next part of the story
but I was really happy with the way they pulled
things off and there's so much to talk about so
be sure to go see the movie as soon as possible
my videos for the ending post-credits scene full
breakdown Easter eggs will start posting Thursday
and Friday so look up for those everyone click
here for my Spider-Man across the spider-verse
ending and post credit scene video and click here
for that full breakdown in Easter eggs for the
entire movie I'll update the links as soon as I
post those thank you so much for watching everyone
stays safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!